Oh
yes and no I mean what is the gay
community you know there's a lot of
different communities within the gay
community there's gay men lesbian women
there's men of color there's a Shingon
there's latino gay men and there's
transgender people bisexual people and
each one of those sub sections of the
gay community has their own identity
their own ways of thinking and
communicating a lot of times they like
to just hang out with similar members of
their own communities
you know I'm all about keeping it real I
don't really give a fuck about the LGBT
media I don't really care about them
that much anymore because the LGBT media
is very not all of them well I do mean
what's interesting is over the course of
time the LGBT media's perception of me
has shifted at first they hated me and
they still are kind of not very
embracing of me but I find it that it's
always tricky to generalize but if you
look at a magazine like The Advocate or
out the majority of people working there
are gay men and white gay men so whether
they try to be objective or not and
whether they try to be inclusive or not
inherently it's not going to really be
all of those things just by nature of
its composition
obviously I come from a slanted
perspective I used to work at GLAAD and
I think glad is a useless organization I
want to start my own gay nonprofit
called happy homosexuals and perverts
protecting you
I think perverts are far under looked we
need more pervert action in America I
mean also and this is I don't really
mean perverts but one thing glad is way
too politically correct they are afraid
of sex and trying to keep that aspect of
gay life in the closet when it's not the
most important but it is an important
part of gay life and we should embrace
it all you know we should be more
sex-positive and I don't see glad doing
work in the field I think that lambda
legal there in the trenches man they're
making stuff happen the the the
grassroots work that people like dan
Choi are doing that people on the
internet are doing themselves with their
friends that is what is really bringing
about change and getting people
activated and excited I mean I remember
being in California around that whole
prop 8 time and when it was overturned
and then all the developments and the
marches and the rallies and was glad
doing anything no most of the things
that happened then or because of people
on the internet that were citizen
activists and that's really exciting I
love the internet and i love that social
media has really helped make your
average gay person involved in the
community and involved in being a
conduit for change